haiya Lewis and I have been talking
about these new very noticeable sort of
frames with what looked like cameras on
the Massachusetts Turnpike which is the
myth that the main highway that runs
east-west throughout the state of
Massachusetts and it actually goes west
the i-90 goes west certainly into the
Dakotas and maybe even further west but
here in Massachusetts it's called the
Massachusetts Turnpike and I finally
figured out what these are Lewis look
what did we think they were ways to
track license plates yes
which they they could be used for that
as well yeah they basically are that but
really the point is that Massachusetts
is getting rid of all toll booths on
i-90 and they are also getting rid of
all 400 toll workers and replacing them
with what are going to be around 15 I
think the exact number maybe 16 or 17 of
these overhead machines which will if
you have one of the transponders in your
car it will connect with the transponder
to bill you for the toll for your usage
of the highway if you don't it will take
a picture of your license plate and then
send you a bill for the toll seems like
kind of a waste of paper but maybe
you're saving a lot in terms of paper
and I don't know all the pay stubs that
the 400 employees aren't getting I don't
really know that the net effect on the
paper side of it and something that's
unique about this is you will no longer
pay right now Louis you sort of check in
when you get on to the turnpike and you
check out when you get off and your toll
is based on the distance traveled this
new system will just have fixed fee
amounts at different points on the
Turnpike so it would be possible to
actually get on and off without paying
any tolled whatsoever around the
Springfield Massachusetts area and a
couple of other areas or you might only
travel a few miles and end up paying a
toll on balance it's expected to cost
about the same amount to travel the
entire Turnpike end-to-end which I've
certainly never done in many many years
of living in Massachusetts so what do
you think about this Louis I mean this
is an example of technological
unemployment we all know it doesn't
really make sense to have
100 people sitting there collecting cash
especially when more and more people
have the transponders it is going to be
a job loss but we are going to be able
to alleviate traffic by eliminating all
of these slowdowns and there will be
advantages here this is a better system
depending on how you do it I this is
with the same thing they did in Texas in
Austin and the problem is that yes your
trip to work may involve getting on the
pike getting off one exit later and now
you're hitting two tolls each way every
time and you're traveling almost a very
short distance that is a huge problem
and I'm not sure how many ways around
that there are but there really should
be and privacy also a concern for people
because their license plates are being
photographed what if police want to
track you down and sort of general
privacy concerns also surfacing around
this of course no right to privacy in
public questions about whether it's
warrantless surveillance or basically
just filming public areas and a lot of
questions about that
what is absolutely undeniable is that
there is no stopping this change in much
of this country because no disrespect at
all to the toll workers these are jobs
which now can be pretty easily replaced
with with relatively simple technology
and it's happening here in October